en unas elecciones empañadas por el
envenenamiento del opositor
alexéi navalni rusia acudió a las urnas
para elegir gobernadores legisladores
regionales y concejales del partido
oficialista rusia unida tiene la mayoría
de los parlamentos regionales pero la
oposición aspira a quedarse con varias
sillas especialmente en siberia con la
municipalidad universitaria de tomsk y
con novosibirsk la tercera ciudad más
importante de rusia y donde navalny
antes de ser envenenado lideraba un
esfuerzo por sacar los funcionarios del
partido de vladimir putin con una
estrategia llamada votación inteligente
en la que promueven cualquier candidato
que no sea oficialista
para cada uno de los 27 distritos de
toms que seleccionamos un candidato que
recomendamos por lo que ahora una
persona puede ir a nuestro sitio
ingresar su dirección registrada y ver a
un candidato que recomendamos esperamos
que este sistema de votación inteligente
funcione pero además de la ausencia de
la principal figura opositora los
comicios están manchados por denuncias
de irregularidades al pasar de 1 a 3
días de votaciones si la estrategia de
votación inteligente funciona la
oposición es para llevarla a las
elecciones legislativas nacionales del
próximo año aprovechando el descontento
social en aumento
causado por las denuncias de corrupción
y abuso de poder y por lo que algunos
rusos consideran un mal manejo de la
pandemia del cobi 19